religious man I believe in God but one
of the stories out of the Bible one of
the most famous stories is what is Adam
and Eve where they eat bite she bit the
apple look at the logo on your phones
so therefore everybody biting them right
now you know what I said on the rhyme I
said most people holding their phones
it's like they two hands holding your
phone it's like you pray to it yeah
think about it like that's what you're
actually doing you're actually sitting
there and praying to this device
it's a cell phone for a reason you're
prisoner to the phone you're in the cell
why is worse than don't because at some
point on dope or on any other substance
abuse you actually realize that you're
hitting rock bottom you will never
realize you're hitting rock bottom and
social delivery he has a great line he
says you don't know how you're going to
know the Matrix if you don't know you're
in The Matrix the only two industries
that call their customers users is
software companies and drugs illegal
drugs we live in a world of criticizing
thinkers I come from a world of being a
critical thing